we've been given some inch for
interesting information here about the
functions F G and H for F they tell us
for given values of X what f of X is
equal to and what F prime of X is equal
to then they define G of X for us in
terms of this kind of absolute value
expression and then it define H of X for
us in terms of both f of X and G of X
and what we're curious about is what is
the derivative what is the derivative
with respect to X of h of x of h of x at
x is equal to 9 and so i encourage you
to pause this video and think about it
on your own before I work through it so
let's think about it a little bit so
another another way just to get familiar
with the notation of writing this the
derivative of H of X with respect to X
at x equals 9 this is equivalent this is
equivalent to H let me do it in that
blue color it is equivalent to H Prime
and the prime signifies that we're doing
the derivative H prime of H prime of X
when x equals 9 so H prime of 9 is what
this really is actually me do this in a
different color so this is H prime of 9
so let's think about what that is let's
take the derivative of both sides of
this expression to figure out what the
derivative with respect to X of H is so
we get a derivative let me do that same
white color derivative with respect to X
with respect to X of H of X H of X is
going to be equal to the derivative with
respect to X of all of this business so
I can actually just swell just rewrite
it 3 times f of X plus 2 times G of X
plus 2 times G of X now this right over
here this the derivative of the sum of
two terms that's going to be the same
thing as the sum of the derivatives of
each of the terms so this is going to be
the same thing as the derivative with
respect to X
of three times right that a little bit
neater three times f of X plus the
derivative with respect to X of 2 times
G of X two times G of X now the
derivative of a number or I guess you
could say a scaling factor times a
function the derivative of a scalar
times the function is the same thing as
the scalar times the derivative of the
function what does that mean well that
just means that this first term right
over here that's going to be equivalent
to three times the derivative with
respect to X of F of our f of X plus
plus this part over here is the same
thing as two we can make sure I don't
run out of space here plus two times the
derivative with respect to X the
derivative with respect to X of G of X
of G of X of G of X so the derivative of
H with respect to X is equal to three
times the derivative of F with respect
to X plus two times the derivative of G
with respect to X and if we wanted to
write it in this kind of prime notation
here we could rewrite it as H H prime of
X is equal to three times F prime of X
so this whole this part right over here
that is the same thing as F prime of X
so it's three times F prime of X plus
two times G prime of X plus two times G
prime of X and once you kind of are more
fluent with this property the derivative
of the sum of two things is the sum of
the derivatives and the derivative of a
scalar times something is the same thing
as the scalar times the derivative of
that something you really could have
gone straight from straight from here to
here pretty quickly now why is this
interesting well now we can evaluate
this function when X is equal to nine so
H prime of nine is the same thing as
three times F prime of nine plus two
times G prime
nine now what is F prime of nine the
derivative of our function f when X is
equal to nine well they tell us when X
is equal to nine f of nine is one but
more importantly f prime of nine is
three so this part right over here
evaluates that parts three but what's G
prime of nine so let's look at this
function a little bit a little bit more
closely so there's a couple of ways we
could think about it let's actually
let's try to graph it now I think that
could be interesting just to visualize
what's going on here so let's say that's
our y-axis and this right over here is
our x-axis now when does an absolute
value function like this what is this
going to hit a minimum point well the
absolute value of something is always
going to be non-negative
so it hits a minimum point when this
thing when this thing is equal to zero
well what is this thing equal to zero
when x equals one this thing is equal to
zero so we hit a minimum point when x is
equal to one and when x equals one this
term is zero absolute value of zero zero
G of 1 is 1 so we have this point right
over there
now what happens after that what happens
for X greater what happens for X greater
than 1 actually let me write this down
so G of X is equal to and in general
whenever you have an absolute value of a
relatively simple absolute value
function like this you could think of it
you could break it up into two function
or you could think about this function
over different intervals when the
absolute value is non-negative and when
the absolute value is negative so when
the absolute value is non-negative
that's when X is greater than or equal
to zero X is greater than or equal to
zero and when the absolute value is
non-negative if you're taking the
absolute value of a non-negative number
then it's just going to be itself the
absolute value of zero zero absolute
value of 1 is 1 absolute value of 100 is
100 so then you could ignore the
absolute value for X is greater than or
equal to oh not greater than or equal to
zero for X is greater than or equal to X
is greater than or equal to one X is
greater than or equal to one this thing
right over here is
non-negative and so it'll just evaluate
to X minus 1 so this is going to be X
minus 1 plus 1 which is the same thing
as just X minus 1 plus 1 they just
cancel out now when when X when this
term right over here is negative and
that's going to happen for X is this is
going to happen for X is less than 1
well then the absolute value is going to
be the opposite of it you give me the
absolute value of a negative number it's
going to be the opposite absolute value
of negative 8 is positive 8 so it's
going to be the negative of X minus 1 is
1 minus X 1 minus X plus 1 or you could
say 2 minus X 2 minus X now so for X is
greater than or equal to 1 we would look
at this expression now what's the slope
of that well the slope of that is 1 so
we're going to have a curve that looks
like or a line I guess we could say that
looks like this that looks like this for
all X is greater than or equal to 1 so
the important thing remember we're going
to think about we're going to think
about the slope of the tangent line when
we think about the derivative of G so
slope is equal to 1 and for X less than
1 well our slope now if we look right
over here our slope is negative our
slope is negative 1 so it's going to
look like this it's going to look it's
going to look like that but for the
point in question if we're thinking
about G prime of 9 so 9 is some place
out here so what is G prime of 9 so G
prime of nine let me make it clear this
graph right over here this is the graph
of G of X or we could say Y this is the
graph y equals G of X Y is equal to G of
X so what is G prime of 9
well that's the slope when X is equal to
9 well the slope is going to be equal to
1 so G prime of 9 G prime of 9 is 1 so
what does this evaluate to this is going
to be 3 times 3 so this part right over
here is 9 plus 2 times 1
+2 which is equal to 11 so the slope of
the tangent line of H when X is equal to
9 is 11